[Music]
there's a little bit of a trust issue
that you have with the band now because
they're not sure if they can really
believe it yeah i think our fans care if
we win or lose
if we win we win games and nobody's
going to remember this i know that
our jobs have win our job is to win
that's it
adam gase meeting with the media
yesterday first time he had a press
conference since the firing of general
manager mike mckagne and i agreed with a
lot of the things adam gay said
yesterday i cannot agree more with that
final statement all the fans care about
is winning right we get caught up in the
stories in the offseason because what
the hell else are we going to do and
there is drama and intrigue but if your
team is winning all that stuff goes away
it's all about winning and that's what
the fans care about now if you lose all
these things from
march april may get get dragged out of
the closet for further analysis and
consternation but if you win who cares
yeah and that's the bottom line and he's
going all in with sam darnold le'veon
bell the rest of that team and if he
wins nobody's going to care about any of
the stuff that's going on the last week
and a half no no they won't and he like
you said has a lot of pieces to i think
surprise people this year in the nfl and
two i think coming back from where he
was in miami uh he realizes hey i got to
go all in on the coaching stuff i can't
worry about all the personnel gm duties
in the world because it pro it does
affect your coaching to a degree so uh
and no matter who they bring at gm he
can listen to his own you know uh press
conference there and go winning cures
all because even if it's a gm or he's a
little worried oh i don't know if this
guy loves me he might take the first
chance to get me out of town when things
don't go well or if he doesn't if you
keep winning he's going to make it very
hard to do that so
i really think that the jets are one of
those teams to watch out for this year
there's a lot of young talent sam
darnold's really good
and i look at them with gase and greg
williams as an improved football team
that can be a thorn in the side for a
lot of teams in the afc
and chris i think it's critical that
christopher johnson the
ceo and chairman of the jets
refrain from any temptation to hire the
best person available who may have no
connection to gays because i really do
think that's a recipe for trouble
because that person is going to want to
hire his own coach no matter what he
says during the interview process but
that raises the concern that if the new
gm is somebody who is aligned with gase
who has worked with gase who gates knows
that may end up being a yes man gase was
asked specifically yesterday by
reporters will your next general manager
the new york jets be a yes man here's
what he had to say
i don't know i don't really hang out
with yes man so so if it's somebody that
i already know
then it's probably somebody that's not
going to be a yes man
why would that because that's how i
don't associate myself with the people
like that
look
this makes sense you don't but in that
business you can't have a bunch of
sycophants running around saying oh good
idea boss and having no independent
thought of their own if you're going to
survive with a national football league
team as an assistant coach or a front
office executive you better have
independent thought you better have
creative thinking you better be willing
to say in a tactful way i see this a
different way and it's through those
healthy disagreements that are handled
in a professional way without anybody
being over the top or disrespectful
that's how you craft the best possible
plan
the best decisions the best team and
that's true in any professional setting
you can't have a bunch of people running
around just adopting blindly the idea
whoever's in charge then you're never
going to push the organization to get
better so i believe gase when he says
that too i know you can have some you
can have somebody that you have a
relationship with so where you know
where the limits are and you don't go
through that awkward first year or so
where we really don't
understand each other's personalities
but you can still have that relationship
and disagreements somebody who's not
going to do whatever the coach wants him
to do so i get it now
getting there is different
than getting it but i think he gets it
yeah i do think he gets it i do believe
him when he doesn't you know when he
says things like i don't put yes men
around me no i you know like we said to
open the show a little bit you know
having been around adam gates he's just
a no no bs no nonsense type of guy i
mean one of the things i've admired more
about him than anything as a head coach
so far is i feel like his team plays
tough on a weekly basis no matter what
the circumstances are so uh i like that
aspect of him and really bottom line you
look at any successful organization in
football there's not a yes man uh yes
man formula going on you know really hey
listen listen i know new england
ultimately bill belichick makes every
decision but nick caserio who's kind of
the acting gm there he's not afraid to
let his thoughts be known and oh i like
this player if bill doesn't agree with
him he does what he wants but i think
you can go down the list of successful
football teams in the nfl and i could
say yeah head coach gm have a good
working relationship but they're not eye
to eye on every single thing in the
world and they don't get butt hurt when
they don't see okay eye to eye exactly
and again i just like to make this point
clear there was issues in the jets front
office before
adam gates got there we knew there was
we thought maybe mchagney would get
fired at the end of the season and when
you look at the dynamics of the jets off
i mean jeff's front office the issues
there mckagne brian heimerdinger you
hear stories about mcagnen bowing down
to brian heimerdinger almost being his
yes man who was the pro personnel guy so
there was a lot of issues there and to
begin with anyways in the jets front
office and i think gace is getting a
little blame for that there and i don't
think he came in to make a power play in
general anyways
butthurt actually is a recognized word
in the dictionary
adjective meaning good overly or
unjustifiably offended or resentful yes
but hurt but hurt yes i don't i don't
know whether or not there's a hyphen
i don't know whether it's two words but
it is recognized uh by the folks at
webster but
but everything you're saying chris is is
spot on look and and yesterday at one
point they were grilling gates on
whether christopher johnson
sought out gases opinion before firing
mike mckagne and gay said no and the
reporters i think didn't believe it look
i
i i think i mean why do you if it's
obvious as you observe the interactions
between the two guys that it's just not
working it's obvious you don't need to
ask adam gase hey i'm letting this guy
go what do you think of it you glean
that from the interactions and i think
that ultimately is what caused
christopher johnson to make the change
this isn't gase necessarily saying i
want this guy out of here this is your
head coach and your gm being two
entirely different people entirely
different personalities and the the ceo
realizes this is not going to work over
the long haul yeah exactly right i mean
christopher johnson i don't think he's
an idiot i think he's very capable of
realizing the situation and kind of
seeing the writing on the wall and
what's going on there now listen do i
think maybe him and adam gase had a
conversation at some point and adam gase
maybe said gosh there's been this issues
with the roster and there's been this
move that's questionable and this that i
don't like and maybe brought up some
concerns to where christopher johnson
was like yeah damn i already had those
concerns and now he's saying that it
makes me even think about it even you
know in a worse way whatever it may be i
wouldn't be surprised if those
conversations happened but they should
have happened there's issues with that
roster that mike mckagne has built you
know fundamental issues that we went
through year after year after year let
alone some suspect signings and
overpaying guys and whatever it may be
so
i'm sure christopher johnson realized
that i wouldn't be shocked if adam geese
pointed some of those things out when
they talked football at some point to
further emphasize those issues
one of the reports that emerged in the
aftermath of the macagnan firing was the
notion that adam gase did not want
le'veon bell on the team and chris i
believe both of us were careful to point
out it's not about not wanting bell yeah
it's about not wanting to pay as much as
they paid when they were the only ones
in that stratosphere gase was asked
point blank yesterday did the new york
jets overpay for le'veon bell
oh i mean the contract was was what it
was
i mean you can
overpay what i mean every everybody can
criticize contracts
all you want but he's here
i'm excited he's here i think our
players are excited he's here i know our
coaches are i mean you get a chance to
coach a great player a guy that's done
things that nobody's ever done in the
league like we're excited for that
opportunity i'm excited to get him in
the offense so i can start figuring out
what else can we do with them what
hasn't done what could he be great at
in this system
and that's
entirely accurate the idea that you want
him but they could have gotten him for
less but that doesn't matter now he's
there he's under contract and whatever
gay said yesterday worked if you're
concerned that le'veon bell is salty
about these reports the response from
bell via twitter yup let's get it coach
quoting uh a tweet that had some of the
things that gays had to say and that's
that's how you make this work people
last week or oh how's adam gase ever
going to manage this relationship you
just have to say to le'veon bell let's
go do this right let's go play football
and let's get the most out of your
skills and let's let's prove to the
world that the jets didn't overpay for
you yeah exactly right let's let's do
that let's do special things together
and i mean gosh i know adam gates wants
le'veon bell eddie but coach wants
le'veon bell you know and did they
overpay for him sure sure and i don't
think adam gase necessarily denied it
there he kind of kind of danced around
the the conversation a little bit either
way le'veon bell is not gonna be mad uh
that oh man adam gase said we overpaid
for me that you know le'veon bell's
gonna look that and go well whatever my
agent did a good job i got the most
money i possibly could have got i know
this guy wants me as a player and i do
think adam gates with his history and
different offenses and even some of the
stuff he did at the with the running
backs down in miami with kenyon drake
and frank gore le'veon bell's got to see
that and go damn i'm you know in the
prime of my career i'm better than those
football players and uh this guy knows
how to use the running back in a
multitude of different ways to where
yeah i think they can do some big time
things together i don't think there's
gonna be any issues at all here because
of both guys knowing their personalities
and who they are as people and two i
think adam gase is going to go out of
his way to formulate a lot of offense
around le'veon bell and of course that's
going to smooth things over with the
player too
once upon a time the new york jets were
known as the new york titans now the
tennessee titans entering their third
decade of existence we're going to take
a look at what they have done or haven't
done in this offseason to improve their
outcome from 2018 more pft live right
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports